la crise de 2015 la crise des réfugiés
personne ne venant veut en europe et en
gala merkel dit l'allemagne en
accueillera un million et elle dit cette
phrase qui resté célèbre on va y arriver
est-ce qu'ils y sont arrivés
est ce que l'allemagne aujourd'hui avec
un million de réfugiés en plus et de
plus qu à peu près de 250 mille par an
est-ce que ça va alors ça fait monter
l'extrême droite enfin de ce côté là
nous aussi on a accueilli quasiment
personne
est ce qu'elle a réussi vous avez raison
ça fait quand même monter l'extrême
droite est redescendu d'huile d'accord
mais enfin c'est quand même pas rien
deuxièmement
ça a donné aussi un argument pour dire
au fond c'était à même la meilleure
façon de faire de faire encore une
pression sur les salaires et donc
quelque part or je pense qu'il ya une
part d'humanité évidemment oui je pense
que c'est une fille de pasteur elle
pense aussi à son salut parce que on
était quand même sauvé jusque là elle
est vite on est elle estime qu'elle
évite une catastrophe humanitaire voilà
est donc l est les eps davis là comme je
disais elle pense à son salut je dirai
au regard de l'histoire puisque on
arrive presque en fin de course mais il
faut bien avouer que ça aussi contribué
à faire baisser le coût salarial
notamment dans le secteur de
l'agroalimentaire et puis deuxièmement
ça aussi ça a été un coup supplémentaire
pour dire au fond la compétitivité
allemande
lll on gagne quelques points en
compétitivité puisque on arrive malgré
l'instauration d'un smic qui est quand
même assez bas on arrive tout de même à
contenir les salaires et puis on
continue à exporter puisqu'on arrive à
gérer maintenir des coûts qui sont
relativement stables
[Musique]